la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le procès
verbal est donc adopté sous les réserves
d'usage madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues notre ordre du jour
appelle les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site internet chacun sera
attentif au respect des uns et des
autres et au respect du temps de parole
et je donne la parole immédiatement au
président Guillaume Gontard pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre 30 jours 30 jours que
Gaza est bombardé jour et nuit 30 jours
de siège sans aide humanitaire sans eau
sans vivre sans refuge 30 jours qui
transformment cette prison en cimetière
à ciel ouvert avec des milliers de morts
civiles dont des milliers d'enfants 30
jours où le droit légitime à se défendre
s'est transformé en vengeance aveugle et
illégal 30 jours d'angoisse pour les
otages et leurs familles 30 jours de
violation du droit internationale 30
jours où souscouvert de combattre le
terrorisme on le nourrit et le renforce
Dominique de Villepin le rappelit encore
hier ni la force ni la vengeance
n'assure la paix et la sécurité seule la
justice peut le faire 30 jours que nous
attendons une parole fortes et claires
de la France pour in cesser le feu le
retour de l'aide humanitaire et la
libération des otages le soutien
inconditionnel de la France aux
opérations militaires d'Israël et à
l'occupation est une erreur tragique qui
marquera l'histoire de façon dramatique
cela ne sert ni les Israéliens ni les
Palestiniens depuis 10 ans la France a
vendu 209 millions d'euros d'armes vers
Israël bomb roquettes missile utilisé
contre la population de Gaza la France a
pourtant ratifié le traité sur le
commerce des armes de l'ONU dont
l'article 6 prévoit l'arrêt des
exportations si ces armes sont employées
pour commettre un génocide des crimes
contre l'humanité des état des attaques
dirigées contre des civils ou des des
crimes de guerre nous ne pouvons pas
attendre un jour de plus madame la
Première ministre à la veille de la
conférence humanitaire la France a une
occasion de faire entendre une voix
forte singulière et courageuse
comptez-vous adopter un embargo sur les
ventes d'armes comme l'avait fait le
général de Gaulle lors de la guerre des
6 jours comptez-vous reconnaître l'état
palestinien comme l'a voté le Parlement
en 2014 comptez-vous appeler à l'arrêt
et au retrait des colonisations pour
préserver la solution à deux états
madame la Première ministre face à cette
folie meurtrière nous avons besoin de
réponsse précis
[Applaudissements]
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Guillaume
Gontard depuis les terribles attaques
terroristes perpétrées par le Hamas
contre Israël la situation dans la
région est extrêmement
préoccupante Israël a le droit d'assurer
la sécurité de son territoire mais cela
doit se faire dans le respect du droit
international et nous devons
impérativement éviter l'escalade et
l'embrasement dans la région et je le
dis sans ambiguité la situation
humanitaire dans la bande de Gaza est
dramatique le bilan humain est
extrêmement lourd avec de nombreuses
victimes civiles notamment des femmes et
des enfants les populations
palestiniennes ne doivent pas payer pour
les crimes du Hamas elles doivent être
protégé de toute urgence cette ur
la France n'a cessé de la réaffirmer et
nous avons condamné très clairement les
frappes contre les personnels
humanitaires et les site de l'ONU comme
nous l'avons dit le droit international
humanitaire impose des principes clairs
de distinction de nécessité de
proportionnalité et de précaution la
protection des civils est à la fois un
appéatif moral et une obligation
internationale une trêve humanitaire
immédiate et dur est absolument
nécessaire elle doit pouvoir mener à un
cesser le feu monsieur le Président
Gontard la France est mobilisé pour la
paix à l'initiative du Président de la
République une conférence humanitaire
internationale pour la population civile
de Gaza se tiendra demain à Paris
j'ajoute que nous suivons de très près
la situation de nos ressortissants dans
la bande de Gaza nous nous mettons tout
en œuvre pour leur permettre de revenir
en France plus de 100 ont pu quitter
Gaza depuis vendredi dernier de plus
nous restons mobilisés pour obtenir une
libération immédiate et sans conditions
des otages monsieur le Président Gontard
face à ce conflit la seule issue
possible est une solution politique avec
deux états c'est la position invariable
de la France c'est le sens de
l'initiative pour la paix et la sécurité
pour tous porté par le Président de la
République autour de trois piliers la
sécurité avec une lutte implacable
contre le terrorisme le soutien
humanitaire avec une réponse
internationale rapide et forte face à
l'urgence de Gaza et la détermination à
relancer un processus politique
permettant de garantir la sécurité
d'Israël et la création d'un État pour
les populations palestinienne face à la
situation au Proche Orient la France ne
ménage aucun effort pour éviter
l'embrasement pour protéger les civils
et pour offrir une perspective de paix
je vous remercie merci Madame la
pruniste la parole est au président
Dominique de leège pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre mes chers
collègues plus de 1000 actes antisémites
depuis le 7 octobre des croix gamés des
étoiles de David tagué sur les murs des
lettres de menace des Français parce
qu'ils sont juifs
sont agressés verbalement et parfois
même physiquement jusqu'à leur domicile
une haine qui s'affiche même jusque dans
le
métro madame la Première ministre
comment comment la France en est-elle
arrivée là quelles sont les causes selon
vous et comment comptez-vous lutter
contre cet
antisémist d'atmosphère qui cangrainene
notre
société pour vous répondre à la parole
est au ministre l'intérieur mon
géralanin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le
sénateur il est tout à fait vrai qu'il y
a en France une explosion des actes
antisémites c'est fait étent déjà haut
avant l'attaque terroriste du Hamas
contre la population
israélienne mais il est évident que
désormais les 1159 actes antisémites
relevés depuis le 7 octobre dernier
correspondent à trois fois plus
d'événements antisémites queun pour
toute l'année
c'est événements dramatiques des
agressions verbales des croixgamés en
effet des étoiles de David posées là où
on pense qu'il y a des Français de
confession juifes qui habitent des
agressions physiques aussi vous l'avez
dit ont fait naître 518 interpellations
par la police et par la gendarmerie
parce queà la demande du Président de la
République et de la première ministre
nous avons dès le premier jour dans les
950 lieux où les Français de confession
juives ont l'habitude d'amener leurs
enfants à l'école vivre leur culte ou
simplement vivre nous avons mobilisé
quasiment 11000 policiers gendarmes et
militaires de sentinelle qui ont pu
protéger donc contre de très nombreux
actes antisémites et interpeller des
personnes qui voulaient passer à l'acte
je voudrais aussi dire monsieur le
sénateur que la haine est traquée sur
Internet et désormais c'estes 7726
signalements qui ont été adressés à la
plateforme os et nous avons identifié
296 de ces personnes faisant nêtre
encore aujourd'hui de nombreuses
interpellations pour que la haine et les
menaces sur Internet soit évidemment
condamné par la justice j'ai pris des
dispositions très claires pour que les
personnes qui sont étrangères 120
d'entre elles sur les quasi 500
interpellations voil leur retrait
systématique de titre de séjour une
quarantaine d'entre eux sont en centre
de rétention administratif et nous avons
déjà commencé comme vous l'avez vu les
éloignements parce qu'on ne peut pas
toucher un français de profession juif
un juif en France sans toucher toute la
République et je veux vous dire
malheureusement que c antisémite touche
tout l'Occident mais en France les
Français de confession juives tous les
Juifs en France ont l'absolue protection
de la République toucher à un juif en
France c'est touché on le sait toute la
France les policiers et les gendarmes
pour qui ont pris tous les samedis à la
synagogue le savent très bien et rendent
au juifs de France un peu de la
protection et de l'amour qu' leur donne
[Applaudissements]
merci
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre merci de
cette réponse mais vous conviendrez avec
moi que pour traiter le mal il faut le
prendre à la racine il faut accepter
d'identifier sans tabou ses origines et
ses ressorts l'antisémitisme déguisé en
compassion palestinienne se nourrit du
wisme et de sa haine de la culture
occidentale dans ce domaine comme dans
tout
autre dans ce domaine comme dans tout
autre il n'y a pas de place pour le en
même temps oui il y a une culture
française qui puiss ses valeurs dans
notre histoire judéo-chrétienne comment
s'étonner de l'échec de l'intégration si
nous doutons nous-mêmes de notre
histoire de nos valeurs de notre culture
lorsque nous les dédigerons pas au nom
du
multiculturalismeér
et que nous avons sous couvert de
tolérance ou d'accommandement
d'irraisonnable renoncer à notre
identité et à notre culture pour épouser
un relatisme culturel qui montre
aujourd'hui ses limites et ses effets
d'lé terires depuis de nombreuses années
des voix se sont élevé nous avons refusé
de les entendre déjà en
1894 en
1894 Anatole France dans le l rouge
écrivait l'antisémitisme
c'est la mort entendez-vous de la
civilisation européenne des propos bien
d'actualité
merci la parole est à notre collègue NAD
JAV pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et
indépendants merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues du Pas de
Calais à l'occcitanie les tempêtes
siaran et Domingo sont traversé notre
pays la Bretagne et le finisterère en
particulier ont été lourdement touchés
des rafales de 207 km/h à la pointe du
rat 193 km/h à l'île- de bas trois
personnes ont perdu la vie dans l'aine
au Havre et à pontavine dans le
Finistère où Frédéric Despo employé
d'enedis est décédé en intervention je
souhaite également souligner le
remarquable travail du préfet du
finisterère à travers lui l'ensemble de
la chaîne de secours et les services de
l'État avec le déclenchement du
dispositif fr alerte et la
sensibilisation de la population en
amont des vies ont probablement été
sauvées je n'oublie pas la formidable
implication de nos élus et de nos agents
territoriaux qu'il soit dans cet
hémicycle remercié vivement des
difficultés perdurent évidemment manque
d'électricité d'accès au téléphone suite
à de nombreux dégâts les Finistériens
impactés sont résilients et solidaires
mais l'inquiétude est immense
particulièrement dans le secteur
agricole dessert cassés écrasés des
bâtiments parfois anciens dégradés des
éleveurs privés d'eau et d'électricité
la profession évalue le préjudice pour
la ferme finistérienne à près de 200
millions d'euros c'est considérable
aujourd'hui leur leur moral est très
affecté plusieurs agriculteur
agriculteurs me le disent il sera
difficile de repartir ils ont besoin
d'un soutien fort monsieur le ministre
comment aider et faciliter les démarches
s'assurer que les matériaux de
reconstruction sont disponibles que les
aides PAC ne seront pas pénalisés par la
perte des arbres quel accompagnement
pour des agriculteurs toujours au
rendez-vous de la solidarité ils l'ont à
plusieurs fois prouvé aujourd'hui ils
dégageent encore les arbres sur les
routes l'an dernier ils aidaient les
pompiers à éteindre le feu dans les
monondaré je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire monsieur
Marc fou merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice à av
d'abord pour me joindre à ce que vous
avez dit c'est-à-dire saluer l'ensemble
des services publics ceux des
collectivités locales et ceux de l'État
qui se sont mobilisés durant cette
tempête rendre hommage aussi aux trois
victimes à la victime évidemment à la
personne qui travaille pour réis qui
venait d'une autre région et qui était
venu en renfort dans votre propre
département et rendre hommage à toutes
celles et ceux qui se sont battus pour
essayer de ici rétablir l'électricité ou
de répondre à les détresses de tel ou
tel vous m'interrogez en particulier sur
la question de la détresse des
agriculteurs et qui ont été
particulièrement touchés comme d'autres
j'y pense aujourd'hui aussi sont touchés
en en particulier dans le Pas de Calais
parce que c'est une succession
d'événements climatiques que nous avons
devant nous je vourrais vous donner les
éléments de la palette de solutions sur
lesqueles nous travaillons pour
commencer à vous donner des éléments
concret sachant que je me rendrai la
semaine prochaine dans le Finistère dans
votre département pour évoquer ces
questions s'agissant d'abord des pertes
de récotte c'est c'est le nouveau
système assurantiel que vous avez voté
d'ailleurs au Sénat aussi qui va entrer
en vigueur qui va s'appliquer deux
précisions la première c'est que le
nouveau système prévoit une indemnité de
solidarité y compris pour les non
assurés donc qui pourront être couverts
en partie par ce système deuxièm
parfois le seuil de 50 % des pees pour
accéder à ce système assuranciel est un
peu trop bas si je peux dire ou un peu
trop selon la façon dont on le regarde
on est en train de regarder s'il y aura
s'il y a des trous dans la raquette et
s'il y a un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs qui ne seraient pas trop
touché et qui nécessiteraiit pas qu'on
ait par exemple un fond de soutien ou un
fond de crise comme on l'a pu le faire
sur d'autres événements climatiques type
grê ou gel et donc on travaille dessus
pour compléter si jamais ils ne peuvent
pas accéder à cela deuxièmement vous
avez évoqué aussi les pertes de fonds
qui sont des pertes importantes je pense
aux fraises mais pas seulement aux
fraises certains relèvent du régime des
catastrophes naturel le ministre daranin
l'a dit hier sur d'autres relèves de du
régime des calamités agricoles comme l'a
dit le président de la République nous
allons activer ces deux mécanismes dans
les jours qui viennent selon les
critères que vous connaissez nous sommes
en cas en train de regarder donc les uns
seront couverts par catastrophe naturell
les autres par régime de calamité selon
la nature de l'ouvrage nous sommes en
train de regarder s'il y a pas nécessité
d'aller plus loin je note avec intérêt
d'ailleurs ce qu'a dit le président de
la Région Bretagne qui était qui a dit
qu'il était capable en souhait de
soutien sur les questions
d'investissement et donc nous
regarderons en complément de ces
dispositifs s'il y a pas lieu
d'accompagner les investissements enfin
juste un mot pour dire qu'on a besoin
d'aller vite il y a des besoins de
madœuvre il y a des besoins de matériel
et nous sommes aussi en train de les
documenter pour faire en sorte que
rapidement la mise en production puisse
se refaire dans un département très
touché comme beaucoup d'autres
départements de
l'Ouest merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue Lord D'cos pour le groupe
des indépendants République et
territoire merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
alors que s'ouvr aujourd'hui les Assises
Nationales des départements de France je
souhaiterais évoquer la question de
l'accueil des mineurs non accompagné
l'afflux massif des mineurs isolés
étrangers sur le territoire français
constitue un véritable casse-tête pour
les départements qui assurent la
protection d' enfance même s'ils ont
conscience que cet exode reste
dramatique pour la plupart d'entre eux
leur prise en charge pe très lourdement
sur les budgets départementaux 1,5
milliard d'euros à minima et les
compensations financières de l'État sont
dérisoires à l'heure où les droits de
mutation à titre onéreux sont en train
de s'effondrer ce sont 80 millions
d'euros en moins pour mon département de
lessonne par exemple il n'est pas
incongru d'exiger de l'État un soutien
plus conséquent les structures d'accueil
sont saturées malgré les efforts des
départements pour dégager de nouvelles
solutions d'ébergement
spécialisé de plus la loi relative à la
protection des enfants dit la loi taé
interdit à partir de 2024 l'hébergement
dans les hôtels de mineurs confiés à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance j'avais
déposé sur le projet de loi de
immigration et intégration deux
amendements l'un pour demander que
l'accueil des mineurs de plus de 16 ans
puissent être réalisé dans des
structures d'hébergement hôteliier en
mobilisant des dispositifs
d'accompagnement le second pour exclure
toute prise en charge des mineurs
délinquants par la zeu ils ont
malheureusement été déclarés
irrecevables au titre de l'article 40
madame la ministre les départements
demandent la mise en œuvre de deux
mesures d'une part le transfert à l'état
de la compétence de mise à l'abri des
personnes se présentant comme mineurs
non accompagnés le temps de l'évaluation
de leur minorité par le Département
d'autre part la compensation à l'euro
près des dépenses engagées pour la prise
en charge des MNA reconnu comme t aussi
je souhaite vous poser les questions
suivantes tout d'abord la politique
migratoire étant une compétence
régalienne l'État est-il prêt à tendre
la main au département dans l'accueil de
ces jeunes migrants au moment de leur
arrivée sur le territoire français
deuxièmement l'État est-il prêt à un
effort financier conséquent et pérenne
pour soulager les départements et les
personnels de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
pour qu'ilaccueille des MNA est un défi
permanent je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à la ministre
déléguée chargé des collectivités
territoriales madame merci Monsieur
Merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice D'cos alors permettez-moi pour
commencer de rappeler un principe auquel
je suis nous
sommes profondément attaché un enfant
isolé sur le territoire français doit
quel que soit sa nationalité être
protégé le doigt français consacre
explicitement ce principe c'est pourquoi
tout mineur non accompagné confié à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance laaz est pris
en charge dans les mêmes conditions que
les enfants de nationalité française
depuis 2016 l'État soutient les
départements à travers un dispositif de
répartition équilibré des MNA sur le
territoire mais aussi une aide
financière pour compenser une partie des
coûts liés à leur prise en charge la loi
du 7 février 2022 a fait évoluer la
prise en charge des MNA au bénéfice de
tous pour protéger les enfants mais
aussi parce que cela arrive lutter
contre les abus et réprimer ceux qui ne
respectent pas les règles depuis ce
printemps nous avons renforcé les moyens
à la frontières et dans les services de
l'État dans les Alpes Maritimes
particulièrement qui ont été les plus
touchés le Pr fait à réquisitionneré des
locaux nous avons proposé une aide pour
évaluer ces mineurs début septembre le
gouvernement a lancé une enquête flash
pour faire un état des lieux des
difficultés de prise en charge rencontré
par les départements et en tirer les
leçons sur cette base avec Charlotte
cobel avec Gérald armanin avec Éric
Dupont Moretti autour de madame la
Première ministre nous travaillons à des
solutions de moyens et de long terme
nous ferons tout pour trouver un
consensus avec les départements c'est
sur la base de cette mission et de la
concertation avec l'ensemble des acteurs
que nous pourrons alors prendre des
mesures pertinentes il s'agit d'enfant
notre mobilisation est totale et entière
et je complète en disant que vendredi
nous irons à l'Assemblée des
départements de France autour de madame
la Première ministre et que nous aurons
l'occasion d'échanger avec eux
directement
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Christian Billac pour le Grou du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues mes amis au secours c'était le
cri d'alarme de l'abbé Pierre il y a
bientôt 70 ans marquant son combat en
faveur de sa logie aujourd'hui les
contraintes de rénovation énergétique
les spéculations sur les locations
saisonnières le zan l'inflation les taux
d'intérêt d'emprunt élevés sont autant
de facteurs aggravant la crise du
logement déjà le secteur du bâtiment qui
représente 6 % du PIB
1273000 salariés et 43000 entreprise
artisanal en rç les répercussions les
chiffres sont alarmants nombre de permis
30 % mise en chantier 21 % construction
individuelle 24 % chute des ventes entre
33 et 38 % quand le bâtiment va monsieur
le ministre tout va mais quand il ne va
pas monsieur le ministre il faut agir
rapidement car le secteur du bâtiment
est un pas beau beaucoup de temps
s'écoule entre le moment où on remet les
moteurs en route et le moment où le
navire retrouve sa vitesse de croisière
mais sit faation vous supprimez le
dispositif Pinel et vous écartez nombre
de communes de nouveaux prix à tau zéro
et une fois de plus ce sont les
territoires ruraux supposé hension qui
sont oubliés et pourtant les besoins en
logement il sont énormes et l'accès à la
propriété est un fort facteur
d'attractivité sans aide l'accès à la
propriété pour les jeunes couples est
quasiment impossible alors qu'ils
assurent la survie des communes rurales
leur viité sociale et associative sans
jeune couple plus d'écoles c'est
pourquoi je vous demande que les zones
rurales soient éugibles aux nouvelles
conditions du PCZ vous assurerai ainsi
l'attractivité rurale qui sans cette
décision continuera encore est toujours
à se
désartifier pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre délégé en charge du
logement Monsieur Patrice bergrd vous
avez la parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs et sénatrice
monsieur le sénateur bac comme je l'ai
évoqué hier en commission des affaires
économiques il nous semble nécessaire de
faire évoluer notre modèle de
développement territorial pour l'adapter
aux nouveaux enjeux auxquels sont
confrontés not nos territoire
aujourd'hui le lien emploi logement la
transition écologique la diversité des
situations locales pour nen citer que
que quelques-uns c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons faire évoluer
les instruments de la politique du
logement et plus particulièrement le
préato zéro dans le cadre du projet de
Bo finance nous avons donc proposé de
prolonger le préat zé jusqu'en 2027 et
de l'adapter aux différentes situations
locales en zone tendue là où il faut
absolument construire de nouveaux
logements
nous avons souhaité le concentrer sur le
neu avec davantage de public éligiblebl
et une aide renforcé augmenté en zone
détendue nous avons déjà maintenu
l'accession sociale à la propriété dans
le 9 et donc en BRS en PSLA et dans les
quartiers de la politique de la ville
pour le reste des Primot acccédentss
nous avons choisi de nous concentrer sur
l'acquisition rénovation 3000 pourquoi
ce choix quelques chiffres pour
l'illustrer dans la Creuse aujourd'hui
nous avons plus de la moitié des
logements qui sont en diagnostic de
performance énergétique FG des poirs
thermiques et nous avons un taux de
vacances de 15 % dans le Cantal c'est 43
% de passoir thermique et 12 % de
vacances vous comprenez évidemment que
dans ces territoires il nous faut
privilégier l'aide publique sur
l'acquisition rénovation à cela s'ajoute
la prime de s à la vacance initié dans
le cadre de France ruralité animé par
Dominique fort ma collègue et je suis
tout à fait prêt d'ailleurs avec
Dominique à signé des pactes de
rénovation avec les départements les
intercommunalités et les communes qui
seraient volontaires justement pour
engager cette transition demain et
adapter nos études politiques du
logement aux réalités locales merci
monsieur le
sénateur notre collègue husin Borg pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègu l'écrivain martiniqu Fran Fanon
écrivait il y a 70 ans quand on parle
des Juifs dresser l'oreille c'est de
vous qu'on parle madame la Première
ministre cela fait 5 semaines que les
Françaises et les Français dressent
l'oreille ils sont inquiets ils sont
horrifiés ils sont scandalisés par la
résurgence de l'antisémitisme en France
pas un jour ne passe sans que notre pays
n connaissent une nouvelle agression une
nouvelle menace une nouvelle dégradation
une nouvelle mise en cause contre nos
compatriotes de confessions
juives cette réalité là nous scandalise
l'antisémitisme qui n'a jamais disparu
de la société française redouble
d'acquuité il s'étale sans complexe il
menace il sévit il empoisonne la vie de
nos concitoyens de nos
compatriotes madame la Première ministre
toutes les forces politiques
républicaines et démocratiques se
Mobilis se dresse votre gouvernement
aussi le président du Sénat à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale ont
appelé à une manifestation dimanche
prochain c'est une heureuse initiative
merci monsieur le
président
madame la Première ministre nous avons
besoin de savoir aujourd'hui quelle est
la jeunèe de ces faits quels moyens sont
mobilisés quelle est la volonté du
gouvernement afin de lutter contre la
résurgence de l'antisémitisme afin que
chacun et chacune d'entre nous prenne sa
part toute sa part et sa juste part
contre ce
fléaure la parole est au ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le le
Président comme je l'ai répondu tout à
l'heure à la question de notre collègue
monsieur delè che plus de 11000
policiers gendarmes mobilisés avec les
militaires de Sentinel pour 950 sites où
les Français de confession juives ont
l'habitude de se
rendre il y a eu l'interdiction de
manifestation dans les heures dans les
jours qui ont suivi les attaques
islamistes du Hamas contre les
populations israéliennes qui ont empêché
il me semble que la France que Paris
n'est pas vécu ce qu'elle avait sur vécu
en 201324 où on a crié mort au juifs
dans les rues de Paris mais aussi dans
d'autres grandes villes européennes je
pense à Berlin où on a attaqué des
synagogues à coup de cocktail Molotof
fort heureusement grâce à la fermeté de
l'État grâce à la présence des policiers
des gendarmes cela n'est pas
arrivé vous posez la question de savoir
qui sont les personnes qui sont passées
à Act malheureusement je veux vous dire
qu'ils sont souvent très jeunes et je
dis au président de la commission des
lois de votre assemblée je suis tout à
fait prêt à répondre à à une commission
qui pourrait m'interroger sur la
sociologie de ces personnes 120
personnes d'origine 120 personnes pardon
étrangères dont une quarantaine
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière
trois fichiers s parmi les 120 personnes
que j'évoque et sur les quasiment 500
interpellations une moyenne d'âge très
jeune pour ne pas dire très très jeune
souvent des min
comme ceux que l'on a vu malheureusement
chanter des champsnasis et de ha juifs
dans le métro parisien identifié par la
préfecture de police et dont l'enquête
mempêche de dire mais évidemment les
choses sont suivies très
particulièrement chaque acte antisémite
sur Internet chaque acte antisémite dans
le monde physique fait l'ouverture d'une
procédure judiciaire et met des services
de police technique et scientifiqu
partout sur le territoire national y
compris pour un graffiti qui veut dire
bien d'autres choses souvent le passage
à l'acte et je sais que la sévérité de
la justice accompagnera tous ceux qui
menacent de mort notamment des rabins ou
des personnes qui sont sensibles pour la
communauté je pense à levois peré
Monsieur le Ministre caruchci où la
police en moins de 20 minutes a su
arrêter avec la plateforme TikTok la
personne la présenté de la justice et
déféré je voudrais simplement dire
monsieur le Président quelques instants
que la haine elle est avant tout sur les
plateformes et nous avons tous à
réfléchir également sur notre accès à
ces plateformes quand 75 % des contenus
antisémites signalés à la police
viennent de Twitter le ministre de
l'Intérieur se dit que les policiers ne
peuTent pas tout faire tout le monde
doit prendre sa
part
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
Madame le première ministre je crois
pouvoir vous dire que sur tous les bancs
de cette assemblée quels que soient les
groupes politiques vous nous trouverez
toujours mobilisés à vos côtés dès
dimanche prochain et pour l'avenir parce
que nous sommes tous et toutes
dépositaires de cette phrase qui
circulait il y a quelques que décennies
en France et en Europe et dans le monde
heureux comme un juif en France cette
phrase là elle nous oblige pour
aujourd'hui et pour
demain la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre Barros pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre messieurs
mesdames les membres du gouvernement
chers collègues la mort du jeune Naël 17
ans tué d'un contrôle routier par le tir
d'un policier a été le point de départ
de 8 jours d'émeutes en France d'une
rare intensité maire de la ville de faos
dans le valdoise pendant cette tempête
urbaine j'ai été comme beaucoup d'autres
élus de France témoin d'ACT de violence
et de dégradation je salue l'engagement
des forces de l'ordre police et
gendarmerie des agents des services
publics des élus et des citoyens pendant
cette période 4 mois après ces tragiques
événements la présentation du plan
gouvernement était très attendue madame
la Première ministre vous avez dévoilé
vos propositions il y a de semaines à
l'amphithéâtre de la Sorbonne j'y étais
et je peux vous assurer que de nombreux
élus sont ressortis déçus vos
propositions restent largement
insuffisantes pour répondre aux enjeux
de nos territoires votre plan mêle à la
fois le tour épressif le contrôle social
et s'impose telle une double peine pour
les familles notamment
monoparentales madame la Première
ministre avez-vous bien entendu ce que
demandent les élus locaux ne pensez-vous
pas que si les communes ont développé
des polices municipales et demande
aujourd'hui leur armement c'est tout
simplement que les forces de l'ordre ont
purement et simplement disparu de leur
territoire de pensez-vous pas que le
tripticque prévention répression
insertion gagnerait à ce que l'État
assume clairement ses compétences
régaliennes lié au maintien de l'ordre
public à ce sujet que proposez-vous pour
la prévention spécialisée si utile dans
nos quartiers pour terminer madame la
Première ministre quand on parle de de
police de proximité on parle de
complémentarité il faut accroître les
effectifs de police et de gendarmerie
nationale sur nos territoires mais il
faut aussi reconnaître le métier de
policier municipal pour ce qu'il est par
une rémunération et une évolution de
carrière à la hauteur de leur engagement
madame la Première ministre
prendrez-vous les moyens de cette
ambition pour vous répondre la parole
est madame la secrétaire d'État en
charge de la citoyenneté de la ville
madame agristiouach vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur Pierre
Barros plusieurs réponses à votre vaste
question mais juste une précision la
Prévention Spécialisée il me semble bien
que ce sont les départements mais des
mesures ont été faites donc vous
m'interrogez sur les réponses apportées
par le gouvernement aux émeutes urbaines
d'abord il y a eu et vous faites bien de
le rappeler les les actions immédiates
de gestion de crise pour établir l'ordre
républicain et c'est ce qui a été fait
avec la mobilisation de moyens
exceptionnels par le ministre de de
l'intérieur des mesures fortes ont été
ensuite prises pour favoriser la
reconstruction avec un projet de loi
dédié tout à fait transpartisant à
l'Assemblée nationale en parallèle
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement a
pris le temps du diagnostic et de la
concertation avec les élus locaux et les
acteurs de terrain sur des solutions à
apporter puis le 26 octobre la première
ministre a annoncé un ensemble de
mesures fortes qui concernne toutes les
dimensions de l'action publique et pas
seulement la sécurité preneant en citer
que trois je commencerai par les forces
d'action républicaines qui ont pour
objectif de renforcer tous les services
publics vous le savez je l'avais dit
plusieurs fois je suis très attaché au
droits communs dans les quartiers
prioritaires simultanément sur tout le
territoire trois de ces Phars seront
déployés à titre expérimental parce que
je pense que c'est le moment où jamais
d'expérimenter des choses comme on
pourrait dire on a tout essayer sauf qui
marche donc c'est peut-être le moment
Besançon Valence maug de plus la
responsabilisation des parents est un
enjeu majeur nous souhaitons créer une
contribution citoyenne en cas
d'infraction commise par un mineur
celle-ci par participera également à
l'indemnisation des victimes parce qu'on
parle souvent trop peu des victimes
aussi à mon sens pour renforcer
l'encadrement des jeunes délinquants ou
descrocheurs nous développerons
également des dispositifs visants à leur
insertion dans une vie citoyenne et
active comme les classes de défense ou
le service militaire
volontaire enfin concernant l'usage des
réseaux sociaux qui vous le savez ont
joué un rôle de catalyur dans ces
émeutes nous créerons une peine
complémentaire de suspension de comptes
utilisateurs en cas d'infraction commis
sur une plateforme en ligne il s'agit
donc d'une réponse multiforme ça serait
trop long de d'énumérer tout ce qui a
été dit et annoncé au CIV et oui le
gouvernement déploie en tout cas sous
l'autorité de la première ministre en en
mobilisant pardon tous les leviers
disponibles pour que ces événements ne
se ne se reproduisent plus monsieur le
sénateur et on pourrait aussi en
discuter parce que les les mesures for
très longes merci Monsieur Merci beauoup
vous avez quelques secondes
oui en effet on a lu les comités de
presse on qui dans le dans les
communiqués moi peut-être que force
d'expérimentation ce serait bien que à
titre expérimental le l'état fe son
travail ce serait déjà pas
mal parole est à notre collègue Olivier
h pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je veux évoquer ici
ce qu'on appellera peut-être demain
l'affaire villemotte Stéphane Villemot
est maire d'une commune du nord au mont
qui a vu l'expulsion d'un imam salafiste
à la suite de son courage et puis de la
volonté du du Préfet et du ministre
c'était on ne peut plus normal puisqu'il
faisait des prêches d'apologie du
terrorisme mais aussi de remise en cause
de notre modèle républicain il est
aujourd'hui en Algérie alors ça aurait
pu s'arrêter là mais seulement demain
Stéphane vilmotte à la suite d'une
citation directe de ce triste individu
sera devant le tribunal alors il s'agit
pas pour moi de faire une quelconque
pression sur la justice elle est
souveraine naturellement mais de poser
quelques questions légitimes première
question est-ce que c'est opportun
est-ce qu'il faut se poser la question
de modifier la législation et c'est le
sens de l'amendement que nous avons
déposé avec Stéphane demilli j'ai des
doutes sur la question mais vous y
répondrez faut-il renforcer
l'accompagnement et et l'aide des
préfets et des procureurs sur les maires
par rapport à cette question faut-il
prolonger le délai d'enquête enfin
toutes ces questions se posent mais ma
conviction notre conviction elle est la
suivante il faut absolument ne pas
laisser les maires seuls c'estes
soutiers de de la République face à
cette question des mariages de
complaisance qui risque de se multiplier
au moment même où nous renforçons à
juste titre et légitimement les
questions liées au au droits des
étrangers je vous remercie prendre la
parole est au ministre de
l'Intérieur merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur ho je veux d'abord
après vous soulignz le courage de
Stéphane vinmotte le maire de Haumont
dans le Nord qui grâce à ses
informations à son action dans cette
petite commune par ailleurs charmante
mais qui a peu de moyens à interpeller
le préfet du Nord vous-même et et
moi-même pour pouvoir expulser cet imam
étranger qui exposait une conv verersion
de l'islam moyenageuse radicale
insupportable et oui nous avons réussi
grâce à l'action du préfet du Nord à
l'expulser et il n'est plus sur le
territoire national avec une
interdiction de retour sur le territoire
national vous avez raison de dire
monsieur le sénateur que par ailleurs
monsieur vilmot paye cher pour lui et
pour sa vie personnelle celle de sa
famille son courage et d'abord il a
l'entière soutien l'entier soutien bien
sûr de la République du ministre de
l'intérieur des services puisque à
plusieurs fois j'ai échangé avec lui et
sa protection bien évidemment physique
lorsqu'il a été menacé je crois que vous
avez parfaitement raison sur les
enquêtes qui doivent durer plus
longtemps sans doute pour permettre à un
maire ou un officier d'état civil
lorsqu'il agit en délégation notamment
de l'État en l'occurrence des services
de la justice lorsqu'il a un doute
lorsqu'il a un doute pour la véracité de
ce mariage et même si un étranger en
situation irrégulière c'est
constitutionnel a le droit de se marier
sur le territoire national en aucun cas
en aucun cas ça ne fait obstacle à son
éloignement ça a été le cas évidemment
pour le cas évoqué aussi à la mairie de
Bézier où bien sûr cette personne a été
expulsée malgré le fait que le procureur
de la République a demandé au maire de
bzier de faire ce ce mariage il y a donc
monsieur le sénateur à réfléchir sans
doute dans le cadre de laimmigration
puisque nous avons adopté hier soir un
amendement de Monsieur bit sur la
reconnaissance fruduleuse de documents
et notamment de paternité passant à un
délit de 5 ans et à une peine de plus de
75000 € d'amande il y a donc à réfléchir
et nous sommes en train d'y réfléchir
donc n'hésitons pas à y travailler
ensemble soit au Sénat soit la navette
soit dans la CMP pour permettre au maire
de décider vraiment lorsqu'il a un doute
sérieux est-ce que ces services lui ont
permis comme c'est le cas de Monsieur
VME de le documenter de s'opposer à
mariage lorsque les gens ne veulent pas
se marier par amour mais par intérêt
contre la
République
nous merci monsieur le ministre pour
votre réponse merci d'avoir souligné le
le courage de Monsieur vilmotte Merci de
la volonté de l'État enfin en tous les
cas on a un devoir c'est de ne pas
laisser les maires seuls parce que je
pense que ce cas n'est pas un cas unique
et qu'il risque de se multiplier par
rapport à les tentatives ou tentations
de mariage de complaisance je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant au
président Cédric Perin pour le groupe
les
républicain
monsieur monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre madame la Première
ministre nous sommes entrés dans une are
où la compétition stratégique entre les
puissance est désormais la norme et où
la lutte contre les ingérences
étrangères est devenue une préoccupation
de chaque
instant la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement on a d'ailleurs fait le
thème central de son dernier rapport son
président rapporteur Sacha Houlier
membre de votre majorité y propose un
plan d'action pour protéger les intérêts
économiques et scientifiques de notre
pays en résumé il vous invite à sortir
du déniis c'est un vœu similaire que
nous formulions le 2 août dernier avec
mes collègues les républicains dans une
tribune intitulé cessons devant endre
nos fleurons les plus stratégiques à des
puissances étrangères nous alertions sur
la décision d'Athos de céder une partie
de son groupe la société P equity
investment propriété de du milliard d'
check Daniel kretansski depuis cette
publication dans les colonnes du Figaro
pas une semaine sans un nouveau
rebondissement chute vertigineuse du
cours d'Atos front des actionnaires
plainte déposé au PNF départ forcé du
président d'Atos ou encore cette semaine
une arrivée très opportune d'un nouvel
investisseur bien sûr c'est une
entreprise privée mais elle n'est pas
une entreprise comme les autres c'est
sur elle et sur ses super calculateurs
que repose une partie de notre
souveraineté nucléaire son
démantelllement et surtout l'imixion
d'acteurs étrangers fustil européens
font peser un risque inacceptable alors
que l'enjeu est crucial comment peut-on
comprendre le silence assourdissant de
votre gouvernement sur cette question
madame la Première ministre reprenez les
choses en main le projet de Monsieur
krtinsk feratil oui ou non l'objet d'un
contrôle au titre des investissements
étrangers en France nous attendons une
réponse
claire rpond la parole est au ministre
délégué du numérique monsieur
bar monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cédric Perin vous avez raison
de le dire Atos n'est pas une entreprise
comme les autres c'est un fluron
industriel français plus de 100000
emplois une présence dans plus de 70
pays et grâce à cette entreprise depuis
plus de 20 ans des savoir-faes
technologiques français qui rayonnent
dans le monde entier et il est vrai que
pour une part certes minoritair de ces
activités atthos représente un intérêt
stratégique pour la souveraineté
numérique de notre pays je pense
évidemment au super calcul puisque Atos
c'est la dernière entreprise européenne
à savoir concevoir et produire des super
calculateurs je pense à la cybersécurité
et à la cyber défense en rappelant
qu'Atos est le partenaire premier des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques pour la
cyber sécurité et je pense évidemment
vous l'avez dit à la supervision de
notre parc
nucléaire cependant contrairement à ce
qui a été proposé notamment à
l'Assemblée nationale et comme l'a
rappelé le ministre de l'économie et des
finances ce matin le gouvernement n'est
pas favorable à la nationalisation
d'Atos parce qu'une telle décision ne
règlerait pas les problèmes
opérationnels et financiers de
l'entreprise et parce que ce n'est pas
de la tutelle de l'État qu'Atos a besoin
mais bien d'investisseurs et de
partenaires industriels ceci étant dit
et pour vous rassurer euh il faut
d'abord rappeler que une prise de
participation en dessous de 10 % ne
confère à celui qui s'y adonne qu'un
qu'une influence très marginale sur la
vie de l'entreprise et que par ailleurs
et que par ailleurs nous n'hésiterons
pas à activer le contrôle des
investissements étrangers en France
comme vous le savez monsieur le sénateur
le code monie et financier soumet toute
prise de participation par un acteur
étranger d'une entreprise d'importance
stratégique en France à une
autoritisation du ministre de l'économie
et des finances soyez assurés que sous
l'autorité de la première ministre le
gouvernement est attentif à l'avenir
d'Athos et à la garantie de la
souveraineté numérique de la
France Merci Merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre réponse ceux qui comme moi
attendaient une réponse claire en sont
pour leur frais et dans dans ce contexte
l'absence de réponse à ma question
obligera le Sénat à exercer son devoir
constitutionnel de contrôle et donc en
apport avec la commission des affaires
économiques la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense exercera son
devoir de contrôle sur
lafferatos par est au président canner
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre depuis la mise en
place de l'Ame aide médicale d'État par
Lionel Jospin en 99 les détracteurs de
cette mesure sont toujours les mêmes
l'extrême droite les extrêmes droite de
leupen à Zemour hier soir le Sénat a
voté sa suppression sans opposition de
votre gouvernement c'est une digue de
plus qui vient de sauter cette
suppression s'est faite sur un fond de
cacophonie gouvernement
le 7 octobre le ministre dararmmananin
se déclarait pour la suppression de la
me ce lundi vous avez déclaré y être
défavorable laame étant je vous cite un
enjeu d'humanité et de santé publique et
ce dans l'attente du rapport stéphanini
Evin ce mardi ici même après un plidoyer
émouvant presque pour l'ame après avoir
indiqué l'attachement du Gouvernement à
ce dispositif et marquer son opposition
à la droite sénatoriale la ministre
firmain le baudau est totalement dédite
en émettant un avis de sagesse synonyme
de blancin pour cette même droite
sénatoriale le soir même son ministre de
tutelle Aurélien Rousseau l'a désavoué
en regrettant cette suppression qu'il
qualifiait de grave
erreur nous partageons l'avis de votre
Ministre le
dernier nous nous élevons contre cette
posture politicienne de la droite
sénatoriale prête à sacrifier la santé
des étrangers et les enjeux de santé
publ dans un calcul électoral
cynique l'ensemble du corps médical est
révolté nos hôpitaux s'en trouvent
fragilisés une certaine idée de la
République sociale est bafouée madame la
Première ministre à quelques heures de
la prévisible suppression des articles 3
et 4 du projet de loi nous n'y
comprenons plus rien sauf à constater la
recomposition de la droite avec votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur à la manœuvre en
conséquence madame la Première ministre
quelle est la position officielle de
votre gouvernement sur le devenir de
l'Ame pour répondre la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Patrick canner vous
avez entamé lundi l'examen du projet de
loi immigration porté par le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald armanin alors vous le
savez ce projet répond à un double
objectif d'une part éloigner plus
rapidement ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester sur notre sol et d'autre part
mieux intégrer ceux que nous choisissons
d'accueillir alors vous m'interrogez
spécifiquement sur
l'ame ma position est sans ambigué c'est
celle de mon gouvernement qui a été
exprimée très clairement
hier la me la
me la me est un dispositif la me est un
dispositif nécessaire qui répond à un
impératif de santé publique il doit
permettre de soigner les personnes
malades qui sont sur notre sol et par
ailleurs l'ame est aussi une protection
pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens car
elle permet de prévenir la propagation
de certaines maladies la prise en
[Applaudissements]
charge la prise en charge au plutôt des
infections respiratoires des hépatites
ou du VIH par exemple est une nécessité
je veux ensuite le souligner l'ame est
un dispositif très encadré et surveillé
c'est même le dispositif le plus
contrôlé de l'assurance
maladie
[Applaudissements]
pour débattre de ce sujet nous avons
besoin d'un diagnostic précis objectif
et actualisé c'est l'objet de la mission
confiée à Patrick stéphanini et Claude
Évin par le ministre de l'Intérieur le
ministre de la santé et la ministre
délégué la ministre a eu l'occasion de
vous le dire hier lors de vos débats cet
état des lieux de la situation est
indispensable il permettra le cas
échéant de proposer des évolution pour
la me nous attendons les conclusions de
la mission d'ici début décembre elles
seront naturellement rendu publi et le
gouvernement en tirera les conséquences
dans la suite du débat parlementaire
mais je veux le rappeler laame a déjà
été réformé en 2019 dans le cadre
naturel qui est le projet doit de
financement de la sécurité sociale
monsieur le Président canner ma méthode
est constante les faits le débat la
recherche d'efficacité c'est l'inverse
même du dogmatisme et des postures cette
méthode c'est celle de mon Gouvernement
sur ce texte comme sur les autres je
vous
remercie notre collègue Françoise
Dumont pour le groupe les
républicains mesdames et messieurs les
ministres M mes chers collègues ma
question s'adressa à monsieur le garde
des saau ministre de la Justice monsieur
le ministre le 27 octobre dernier les
journalistes de RMC ont dévoilé des
éléments du rapport igpn IgA igj sur la
gestion des stocks de procédures
présenté au gouvernement en juin 2023 ce
rapport que j'ai à plusieurs reprises
auprès de vos services et de ceux du
garde d' saau demandé à pouvoir consulé
n'a pas été rendu publici pourtant des
journalistes ont pu s'en procurer un
exemplaire dans ce document il serait
indiqué que l'année dernièr les
commissariats disposaient d'un stock
ancien de 2,7 millions de plin dont un
tiers serait en stock depuis plus de 2
ans auquel il faut ajouter 3 millions et
demi de nouvelles plaintes enregistré
dans le courant de l'année il est ainsi
indiqué qu'en moyenne un policier doit
traiter 180 dossiers par an et pour les
les enquêteurs les plus spécialisés on
parle de 800 dossiers par an le rapport
préciserait ainsi je cite des dossiers
portants sur des faits grave dorment
dans certains services sans avoir fait
l'objet d'investigation alors même que
les les auteurs présumé ont été
identifié et le rapport de conclure
qu'en l'absence de mesures correctrices
et à délinquence équivalente le stock de
procédure pourrait continuer à augmenter
d'ici 2030 passer à 3 millions et demi
de plaines en attente dans un état de
droit il n'est pas possible de laisser
des coupables dehors en toute impunité
dans un état de droit il n'est pas
possible de ne pas répondre au devoirs
de justice vis-à-vis des victimes aussi
Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous nous
préciser si cela est lié à une question
de manque d'effectif pourriez-vous nous
préciser quelles sont les 17
recommandations de ce rapport et si le
Gouvernement entend y donné suite et
quand et enfin et surtout monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous assurer devant
la représentation nationale que
l'ensemble des dossiers seront bien
traités avant la fin des délais de
prescription des éventuels actes
passibles de sanction pénal visés par
les quelques 2,7 millions de dossiers en
souffrance je vous remercie la parole
est minist
l'intérieur merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice c'est justement
parce que nous avons conscience avec le
Gard saut des grandes difficultés
notamment de la filière dite
investigation au sein des forces de
l'ordre que nous avons commandé en effet
aux inspections de nos de ministère un
état des lieux que nous rendrons public
bien sûr et notamment en premier lieu la
représentation nationale il y a en effet
un petit peu moins de 3 millions de
procédures de plaintes qui ne sont pas
en ce moment suivies je quand même que
ces 5 millions son ont fait police et
gendarmerie de plainte qui sont déposé
par an il y a donc évidemment énormément
de dépôts de plainte fait par nos
compatriotes pour de toute forme de
raison qui soi évidemment des choses
extrêmement graves qui touchent les
atteintes physiques ou des choses
matérielles qui sont évidemment tout
aussi grave qui mérite une réponse mais
qui ne sont pas évidemment de la même
urgence pour quels sont les problèmes et
pourquoi il y a eu ce stock et pourquoi
il y a ce stock de procédure d'abord il
faut bien le voir madame la sénatrice
c'est en effet un manque chronique de
police policiers et de gendarmes nous en
avons rajouté grâce à vous puisque vous
avez voté ces texte 17000 dans la grande
majorité faut dire que nous réparonss
beaucoup d'erreur 17000 policiers et
gendarmes de plus mais nous ne pouvons
pas créer ex Nilo des officiers de
police judiciaire le minintérieur ne
peut pas affecter les OPJ on doit
d'abord les former et la dernière loi de
programmation que j'ai fait voter que
vous avez suivi permet de créer les OPJ
dès l'école de police ce qui nous permet
dès cette année d'envoyer désormais dans
les commissariats des jeunes OPJ et non
pas attendre le moment où il passe
exactement ce concours de PJ
deuxièmement une simplification de la
procédure pénale évidemment puisqu'il y
a deux cadres d'enquête l'une qui
consiste évidemment à la flagrance
l'autre à la préliminaire le garde des
saut a fait voter un texte ici qui
prévoit la simplification cette
procédure auquelle vous allez y
travailler la numérisation puisque
toutes les les procédures étaient papi
lorsque je suis arrivé il y a 3 ans au
ministère de l'intérieur c'est plus que
50 % du cas aujourd'hui comme l'IMP à la
source la police doit se moderniser les
moyens auprès des parquets ou des
greffes puisque évidemment les polici
font le travail sous l'autorité des
parquets des greffes les moyens ont été
évoqués lors de la dernière loi justice
et puis bien sûr Madame La la la
sénatrice il est tout à fait évident que
nous allons traiter l'ensemble des
procédures il n'y aura pas d'
prescription lorsque les plaintes ont
été déposées et j'ai donnner comme
consigne que l'on commence en renforçant
d'Urs les effectifs à à toucher en
premier ce qu'on fait des atteintes au
bien et aux personnes pardon et
notamment ce qui touche les femmes et
les enfants merci la parole est notre
collègue Vincent de pour le groupe de
l'Union
centriste merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le 22 mars dernier le ministre
de l'économie et des finances annonçait
publiquement son intention d'interroger
le Conseil d'État sur une un possible
raccourcissement des de la durée des
contrats de concession
d'autoroute le 8 juin le Conseil d'État
rendait son avis entre ces deux dates 22
mars et 8 juin est-il exact monsieur le
ministre que qu'un contentieux aurait
été entamé par les sociétés d'autoroute
pour atteinte à leur
image pensez-vous que ce contentieux a
pu avoir un effet et un impact sur la
vie du Conseil d'État et 3ème question
le Sénat a réclamé un sommet des
autoroutes ce sommet des autoroutes a
été main de fois repoussé
malheureusement souvent annoncé
j'aimerais savoir quand il aura
lieu prendre la parole est au ministre
délégué chargé des transports monsieur
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur de lae chacun connaît ici votre
intérêt votre expertise et si j'ose dire
votre passion pour la question
autoroutière de longue date alors pour
reprendre la chronologie des faites très
précisément en effet avec Bruno Lemer
nous avons annoncé devant l'Assemblée
nationale au mois de mars de manière
tout à fait transparente que nous
allions saisir le Conseil d'État pour
être tout à fait complet sur deux points
l'un qui est celui que vous avez Rapp
appel la possibilité la question de la
durée des concessions pour les contrats
en cours serait-il possible d'un point
de vue juridique évidemment sans une
compensation massive ou significative de
changer ou de raccourcir la durée des
concessions deuxième question très
importante puisqu'elle sera soumise
prochainement dans le cadre du budget
pour 2024 à votre assemblée celle de la
compensation ou plutôt la taxation la
contribution des sociétés autoroutières
notamment à la stratégie de
décarbonation à notre plan
d'investissement pour les trans ort sur
le premier point comme sur l'ensemble de
ces questions je suppose en effet les
sociétés d'autoroute ont déposé un
contentieux je n'ai pas le commenter
nous sommes en état de droit c'est leur
droit je pense que il n'y a un seul cas
dans lequel un contentieux pourrait
avoir un effet sur la saisine du Conseil
d'État sur le plan consultatif dans le
respect de nos règles c'est si le
Conseil d'État lui-même estimait que les
deux questions étaient suffisamment
proche pour suspendre les travaux l'un
de l'autre ce ne fut pas le cas le
Conseil d'État n'a pas décidé idé de
suspendre ces travaux consultatifs et a
rendu un avis que nous avons décidé avec
la première ministre de rendre publ
rapidement dès la fin de l'été sur ces
deux questions d'ailleurs donc pour être
très clair je ne pense qu'en aucun cas
le contentieux qui est un droit sur un
point spécifiqu soulevé par les sociétés
d'autoroute a pu influer d'une
quelconque façon sur l'indépendance du
Conseil d'État dans sa fonction
consultative et le respect des règles a
été entièrement assuré si vous faites
état d'une quelconque pression qui
pourrait être exercée ça ne marche pas
puisque nous nous avons décidé sur le
deuxème point de saisir l'Assemblée
nationale comme le Sénat dans le cadre
du PLF 2024 d'une contribution des
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
quand à l'avenir des concessions je ne
sais pas ce sera un sommet mais en effet
nous lancerons d'ici la fin de l'année
ces travaux associant le Sénat comme
l'Assemblée nationale pour travailler à
l'avenir de nos concessions
autoroutières monsieur
de merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
précisions c'est pas les informations
que j'avais hein il me semblait que le
Conseil d'État a été influencé par le
fait qu'il y ait eu un recours donc
écoutez je je prends acte de vos
déclarations euh je serais sensible au
fait que l'on puisse effectivement tenir
peut-être pas un sommet le le nom
m'importe peu l'important c'est qu'on
puisse dialoguer qu'on puisse dialoguer
avec vous mais qu'on puisse dialoguer
aussi avec les sociétés d'autoroute qui
ne sont pas très ouvertes au dialogue et
que on puisse regarder quel est
l'équilibre financier de ces contrats
vous savez que nous considérons qu'il
est beaucoup ils sont beaucoup trop
profitables et que ces contrats sont pas
adaptés à des vraies concessions et que
ils prévoient notamment des
augmentations de tarifs qui sont lié à
l'inflation alors que euh le résultat
des sociétés d'autoroute et leurs
charges sont assez peu lié à l'inflation
donc moi je vous demande aussi de faire
attention euh à l'augmentation qui va
être annoncée pour 2024 l'augmentation
2023 de 475 % a été très importante elle
permet d'ici la fin des contrats aux
autoroutes aux sociétés d'autoroutes de
faire 4 milliards d'euros de bénéfices
supplémentaires donc je pense qu'il faut
faire très très attention à ces
augmentations je compte sur vous pour
être vigilant et pour montrer que dans
une concession le patron c'est
l'état la parole est à notre collègue
marie-caroleu pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur monsieur le
Président Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le garde
des saau dont nous regrettons l'absence
un maire et sa famille si avec une
tentative d'incendie à leur domicile la
h rose deux mairies intégralement
brûlées à villeneuve-leroi et à Valenton
plusieurs postes de police municipal
attaqués dont ceux de villecine et de
suissiambri pour ne parler que de mon
seul département le valde Marar n' a
payé un très lourd tribut aux émeutes
pourtant 4 mois plus tard s'il y a eu
trois personnes condamnées pour le poste
de police municipale de vicraine il n'y
a eu à ma connaissance aucune autre
suite judiciaire pas même à la î et rose
les émeutes qui se sont déroulé dans
notre pays ont occasionné d'après les
assureurs 650 millions d'euros de dégâts
avec un millier de bâtiments publics
touché ce sont les symboles de notre
République qui ont été visés élus mairie
école commissariat police municipale
lors de la réunion à la Sorbonne le 26
octobre madame la Première ministre a
insisté sur une réponse pénale
exemplaire et le refus total de
l'impunité objectif auquel je ne peux
que souscrire selon les chiffres
communiqués par le gouvernement au cours
de l'été il y a eu 1000 condamnations
principalement à de courtes peine pour
10000 hmetiers mais où en est-on
aujourd'hui la représentation nationale
est en droit de disposer d'un bilan
département par département du nombre de
personnes interpellés du nombre de
personnes condamnées avec le détail des
peines et leur exécution le garde des
saut peut-il nous confirmer que tous les
moyens de l'État sont encore mobilisés
pour mener les enquêtes sanctionner les
vrais coupables et donneurs d'ordre de
de toutes les atteintes graves aux
personnes et aux bien perpétrés durant
quelques jours il en va de la
crédibilité de l'État et de celle des
élus pour vous répondre la parole est à
la secrétaire d'État en charge de la
citoyenneté de la ville vous avez la
parole madame le merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice sur la
période du 27 juin au 7 juillet 2023 66
département et 516 communes ont été le
théâtre de violence urbaines le 30 juin
2023 le gardessau a adressé circulaire
aux procureurs généraux et procureurs de
la République afin qu'une réponse pénale
rapide ferme et systématique soit
adressé à l'encontre des auteurs de ces
exactions le traitement judiciaire a été
effectif et empreint de célérité un taux
de réponse pénale de 92 %, un taux de
poursuite par déferment de 90 %, le
recours à la comparution immédiate a été
massif représentant 60 % des poursuites
devant le tribunal correctionnel près de
1800 personnes ont été condamné à une
peine d'emprisonnement dans le contom de
peine moyenne avoisine les 9 mois de
prison
ferme le ministre de la Justice porte
actuellement 12 mesures concrètes visant
à renforcer la répression envers les
plus jeunes et à responsabiliser leurs
parents parmi celle-ci la création de
placement le pardon parmi ceci la
création d'un placement éducatif de jour
ou de nuit pour les mineurs dont
l'irrespect entraînera son placement en
centre éducatif armée ou en détention
provisoire un partenariat renforcé avec
l'armée pour suivre certains mineurs
délinquants la création d'une
responsabilité civil de plein droit pour
les deux parents de mineurs même s'ils
sont séparés
ou encore l'aggravation du délit de
soustraction d'un parent à ses
obligations légales envers son envers
son enfant voilà quelques mesures assez
fortes qui ont été saluer il me semble
par pas mal d'élus et le gardessau
viendra quand il le pourra vous répondre
plus précisément je vous remercie
madame pour pour le maire de la h rose
qui nous écoute aujourd'hui je pense que
l'espoir d'une sanction de ces
agresseurs s'éloigne encore c'est vrai
que c'était pas comme sil n'avait pas eu
de votre part madame la la première
ministre quand vous êtes venu le voir
l'assurance que ces agresseurs seraient
sanctionnés on l'espère
sincèrement
notreèueim pour le groupealiste l
républicain madame la Première ministre
la tempête carane a très durement
éprouver la Bretagne il faut tout
d'abord saluer l'engagement exceptionnel
des pompiers des forces de l'ordre et de
sécurité civile des agents des
collectivités territoriales et des
opérateurs en particulier d'énedis
honorons la mémoire des victimes et
rendons hommage à Frédéric Despo agent
d'énédis décédé dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions nos pensées vont vers sa
famille et ses collègues éplorés le
monde agricole est très lourdement
impacté la réunion du comité catastrophe
naturelle est annoncée le 14 novembre 2
semaines après le début de la tempête
c'est bien tard il s'agit d'une promesse
du président et de votre gouvernement
hier devant l'Assemblée nationale mais
depuis nous avons eu confirmation que
les dégâts provoqués par la tempête
n'entraient pas dans ce champ de
garantie qu'en est-il précisément sur
l'approvisionnement en électricité quand
vous citez quelques pourcent de foyer à
raccorder au moment où l'on se parle il
s'agite en réalité de plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de bretonnes et de Bretons
qui n'en peuvent plus des promesses non
tenues de très nombreuses défaillances
nous sont remontées tous les jours pas
de téléphone satellitair fournis par les
préfectures et des élus contraints
d'improviser un réseau sib en
finisterère une usine d'eau potable
dépriorisée dans les Côtes d'Armor une
station d'épuration sans électricité
dans le morbillant et un maire obligé
d'appeler le copain d'un copain chez
enedis faute de coordonnées transmises
en amont des élus contraints d'utiliser
leur véhicules pour aller chercher des
groupes électrogènes qui arrivaient en
Bretagne 3 jours après le début de la
tempête un maire obligé de faire six
relances différentes en 6 jours pour
mettre en sécurité deux points critiques
perdu au milieu de nulle part pour
reprendre leur mots obligés d'endosser
des responsabilités majeurs sans les
bonnes informations et sans les moyens
appropriés les maires et les élus sont à
bout la sous-traitance de l'État confine
désormais à la maltraitance nous voyons
là les effets directs du désarmement de
nos services publics du
sous-investissement chronique et de la
logique de flux tendu qui ne nous
permettent pas de faire face aux
épreuves d'un monde qui se dérègle face
à la multiplication prévisible des
catastrophes climatiques il y a urgence
à agir quelles actions concrètes
allez-vous mettre en œuvre pour que ces
situations ne se reproduisent plus pour
la parole est à la ministre déléguée en
charge des collectivités
territoriales merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur usena
alors je rappelle tout d'abord que les
dommages causés par les vents violents
sont couverts par la garantie tempête
des polices d'assurance souscrites par
les collectivité en vertu de l'article L
122-7 du Code des Assurances par
ailleurs vous l'avez souligné monsieur
le sénateur le président de la
République en déplacement dans le
Finistère ce vendredi 3 novembre a
indiqué que l'état de catastrophe
naturelle et celui de calamité agricole
seront déclenchés très vite sur ce sujet
La Réunion comité catastrophe naturelle
se tiendra le 14 novembre vous trouvez
que c'est un peu long c'est quand même
très rapide monsieur le sénateur le
décret paraîtra dans les jours qui
suivent ce mécanisme bénéficiera bien
sûr aux collectivités territoriales et
permettra notamment de couvrir les
dommages liés au phénomène de submersion
ou de débordement des cours d'eau s'il
devait y avoir des difficultés avec les
assureurs pour assurer le remboursement
des dommages nous ferons le nécessaire
avec le Médiateur des assurances dont
vous savez qu'il peut depuis le mois de
septembre être saisi par les
collectivités elles-mêmes nous disposons
enfin de la dotation de solidarité qui
permet dans de tels cas de prendre en
charge les dégâts subis par les biens
des collectivités j'ai demander la
semaine dernière à la DGCL d'adresser au
préfet concernés un message leur
rappelant les conditions d'engagement de
cette dotation de façon à ce que les
prises en charge puissent être rapides
et significatives j'y veillerai
personnellement par ailleurs le ministre
de l'Agriculture poursuit les travaux
d'évaluation des dégâts afin
d'enclencher toutes les procédures de
reconnaissance en calamité agricole dans
les délais les plus courts s'agissant
des pertes de récoltes celles-ci seront
prises en charge dans le cadre du
nouveau système assuranciel y compris
pour les agriculteurs non assurés via
l'indemnité de solidarité nationale
comme à chaque fois nous serons bien
entendus
au côté des collectivités des
agriculteurs et de tous nos concitoyens
je vous remercie la parole est à notre
collègue agès évine pour le groupe les
républicains ma question ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale dès votre prise de fonction et
il y a encore quelques jours vous avez
prononcé des mots forts contre le
harcèlement votre position a été
courageuse par parents enseignants et
victimes tous avaient besoin d'entendre
ce message clair l'omerta était devenu
insupportable les chiffres publiés hier
par l'Ifop pour l'association Marion la
maintendue sont accablants un jeune sur
5 est victime de harcèlement scolaire
c'était auparavant un/ 10 et la moitié
des victimes n'en parl pas près de 80 %
des parents se disent inquiets il y a
urgence les faits je le rappelle sont
sans précédent avant le harcèlement
scolaire s'arrêtait au grilles de
l'école à 16h30 aujourd'hui il se répand
H24 sur les réseaux sociaux avec TikTok
insta ou snapchat qui par leur viralité
démultiplient les conséquences
dramatiques et ne laissent aucun répit
aux victimes vous avez monsieur le
ministre annoncé 30 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour la création de
brigades anti-harcèlement ces moyens
seront-ils suffisant alors que trop
d'établissements gèent la pénurie
pénurie de médecins scolaires pénurie de
psychologu scolaires pén d'infirmière
scolaire pouvez-vous nous confirmer que
tous les personnels seront désormais
systématiquement formés pour prévenir et
détecter allez-vous rendre obligatoire
les questionnaires d'auto-évaluation
alors que les deux heures banalisées
sont facultatives enfin en matière de
sanction pouvez-vous nous préciser la
mise en place des mesures d'éloignement
du harceleur pour protéger la victime
comme notre collègue Marie Mercier
l'avait proposé dans sa PPL Cigné par
215 sénateurs de tous les bancs de cet
hémicycle monsieur le ministre face à ce
hum considérable l'action doit être à la
hauteur de la communication je vous
remercie la parole est au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et la jeunesse
monsieur
Atal merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice évren s'il est une
cause qui peut nous rassembler pardelà
lesé clivage politique je crois
profondément que c'est la lutte contre
le harcellement scolaire ce fléo
absolument insupportable qui fait que
des élèves vont à l'école la boule au
ventre et parfois se donne la mort parce
qu'ils subissent les brimades les
insultes les coups et je vous remerci du
caractère très constructif de votre
question et je vous confirme que pour
lutter contre ce fléo nous avons besoin
de toutes les bonnes idées et que le
groupe LR du Sénat apportter ces
dernières années des idées madame
Mercier laa fait et d'autres et que ça
nous inspire évidemment dans notre
action vous m'avez posé trois questions
très concrètes la première sur la
formation oui nous généralisons le
programme phare qui fait que dans ch é
scolaire vous devez avoir au moins 5
adultes formés avec une vraie formation
sur la lutte contre le harcèlement des
enseignants des personnels de vie
scolaire d'autres personnels aussi on
s'est rendu compte par exemple que
former des agents de la cantine c'était
très utile parce qu'ils voient beaucoup
de choses et qu'ils peuvent aussi
détecter et signaler deuxième chose sur
le questionnaire effectivement demain
est une journée importante chaque année
il y a la journée de lutte contre le
harcèlement les années précédentes
c'était autour d'un tiers des
établissements qui organisaient une
action cette année j'ai décidé que tous
les établissements scolaires devront le
faire et pour vous répondre très
concrètement les 2 heures banalisées ne
sont absolument pas une option ça me
permet de le rappeler que d'avoir cette
question la classe doit s'arrêter
pendant 2h dans tous les établissements
scolaires pour un débat sur le
harcèlement et ce questionnaire
d'autoévaluation que nous avons rédigé
avec Marcel ruffau nicole Catheline Éric
de Barbieux troème question sur le
changement de règle je l'ai dit dès cet
été après ma nomination c'est au
harceleur de quitter l'établissement et
non plus au harceler et oui cette règle
s'applique je vous donne un exemple à
montmarsan un lycée
fait l'objet de harcèlement depuis la
rentrée scolaire le 9 octobre il le
signale au chef d'établissement qui
l'accompagne dans le dépôt d'une plainte
une semaine plus tard les trois élèves
harceleurs âgés de 15 et 16 ans sont
interpellés par les forces de police en
garde à vue ils passeront devant le juge
des enfants le 15 novembre et
entre-temps ils ont été exclus de
l'établissement ce sont plusieurs
dizaines de jeunes harceleurs qui ont
été exclus de leur établissement depuis
que j'ai pris cette décision la peur est
en train de changer de camp la honte est
en train de changer de camp évidemment
il y a encore du travail parce que ça ne
s'applique pas encore partout mais vous
pouvez compter sur ma mobilisation comme
je sais pouvoir compter sur la vôtre
pour
[Applaudissements]
avancer je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre pour vos pour vos précisions je
rappelle que beaucoup d'annonces avaient
été faite notamment il y a quelques
années sur le respect de la laïcité à
l'école et que force de constater
aujourd'hui malheureusement que aussi
rarement le principe de laïcité a été
fragilisé j'ose espérer qu'il n'en sera
pas de même pour la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire je vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Michel Arnaud pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
dans le cadre aussi de l'examen du
projet de loi immigration en cours
l'article 72 78 alinéa 2 du Code de
procédure pénale prévoit que toute
personne peut être contrôlée dans une
zone de 20 km en dessà de la frontière
terrestre de la France avec les états de
l'espace Schengen ainsi si lorsqu'un
étranger arrive sans les documents
nécessaires pour son établissement en
France ou alors qu'il n'en avait pas
l'autorisation il s'expose à un refus
d'entrée sur le territoire et peut-être
placé en zone d'attente le temps pour
l'administration d'organiser son retour
cette procédure de quelques heures
parfois jusqu'à 24h avait prouvé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui son efficacité pourtant dans
un arrêt récent du 21 septembre 2023 la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
estime que la France ne peut pas
procéder au refoulement vers pays voisin
de personnes migrantes entré
illégalement sur le territoire sans
qu'ils puisse bénéficier d'un certain
délai pour quitter volontairement le
territoire sur le terrain cela va donc
se traduire par la mise en place d'une
procédure administrative de réadmission
nécessitant le respect de ce délai
allant à l'encontre du message de
fermeté et d'efficacité clamé par le
gouvernement et aussi par notre
assemblée nous avons donc affaire à une
décision de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne venant
court-circuiter le droit national et
parfois nos propres procédures
administratives et cela dans un contexte
où la gestion des flux migratoires est
très problématique je le constade dans
mon département les Hautes Alpes où les
migrants passent régulièrement entre
l'Italie et la France via notamment
l'école de l'échelle ou de Montgenèvre
malheureusement ni l'accueil de migrants
ni la frontière frontalière ne sont à la
hauteur de nos exigences démocratiques
monsieur le ministre comment l'État va
prendre en compte la décision de la Cour
européenne dans ce contexte de politique
migratoire en particulier en lien avec
le texte que nous étudions actuellement
sur l'immigration je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur
Darmanin monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous le savez dans votre
département des Hautes Alpes ainsi que
dans les Alpes Maritimes nous avons
expérimenté à la demande du Président de
la République une nouvelle façon de
tenir la frontière avec des renforcement
de moyen très important et un
commandement unique pour l'ensemble des
forces de tous les ministères qui
contribuent à la protection de cette
frontières et c'est efficace très
efficace puisqu'on a augmenté de 70 %
depuis le début de cette expérimentation
1er juillet les non mission les retours
dans les pays d'origine et également
vous le savez plus de 60000 refus
d'entrée prononcés depuis le début de
l'année alors évidemment le Conseil
d'État ayant saisi la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne sur la question
préjudicielle que vous évoquez doit
interpréter désormais la décision de la
Cour de justice qui cependant je
voudrais le dire ici parce que j'ai lu
parfois l'inverse mais c'est pas ce que
vous avez dit permet aux États européens
de rétablir des contrôles de frontières
intérieur ce que nous faisons depuis
2015 et ce que nous renouvelons en en
vue d'un évidemment de menaces
terroristes très fortte surtout l'année
2024 qui sera l'année des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques il y a donc
possibilité d'avoir des cont des
contrôles de frontière intérieur c'était
l'objet de la question préjudicielle
puisque le Conseil d'État avait été
saisi par plusieurs associations
militantes et désormais ce Conseil
d'État doit nous dire comment on doit
mettre en place cette retenue qui permet
aux gens de repartir spontanément en
effet dans le pays pour lequel ils ont
traversé une frontière en l'occurence
l'Italie pour ce qui vous concerne nous
pensons nous qu'il y a une possibilité
que le Conseil d'État nous décrit éve
l'action d'une police qui n'est pas
engossée dans plusieurs procédures
administratives ou judiciaaires qui
relèverait plutôt de la garde à vue ce
qui serait sans doute une lecture un peu
restrictive de la décision de la Cour de
justice mais nous pourrions et ce
travail que fait ministère de
l'Intérieur convaincre nous l'espérons
le conseil de l'État le Conseil d'État
qui va pouvoir nous dire comment ces
policiers ces gendarmes peuvent
travailler et nous pensons que le droit
européen sera tout à fait compatible
avec ce que nous faisons notamment dans
le cadre de l'expérimentation du 1er
juillet c'est-à-dire un travail en
commun de tous les actions ministérielle
et donc d'un refus une nonadmission
aussi rapide soit-il lorsque quelqu'un
traverse irrégulièrement le territoire
national donc j'ai confiance dans la
décision du Conseil d'État oui nous
pouvons faire des contrôles intérieurs
oui nous pouvons faire des nonadmissions
espérons qu'on pourra le faire dans la
meilleure simplification possible pour
les policiers
AR merci monsieur le ministre nous
attendons donc la décision du Conseil
d'État je me permets de d'appeler votre
attention sur deux points sur la
frontière italienne dans mon département
la première c'est la nécessité
d'accompagner dignement les personnes
migrantes arrivant à la frontière
actuellement es sont accueillies dans
des bengalo à 1850 m d'altitude et
d'autre part renforcé de manière durable
avec un escadron de gendarmerie
permanent à la frontière dans la partie
centrale de la frontière italienne avec
la France nécessaire pour pouvoir
garantir l'effort et l'efficacité de nos
services
merci nous en avons terminé avec les
questions au Gouvernement merci madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres no prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu le
mercredi 15 novembre à 15h la séance va
être suspendue elle sera reprise à 16h30
pour des désignations suivies de la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi pour
contrôler l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration la séance est
suspendue